[Music]
in YouTube drama news [ __ ] about YouTube
film anymore no I'm fakers [ __ ] anyways
submitted by Ellen [ __ ] Gomez oh
[ __ ] go massage Ellen Gomez
interesting thing it's like the Hispanic
Ellen Allen Oh Ellen ha me 2ln
fouseytube is surrounded by drama after
hosting a free last-minute concert event
wow he's really found his last stretch
it's about this big-ass T that's white
as fun is that here there's really white
teeth gives of the year and he's bald he
has a tattoo he's tattooed is him
looking oh really he's a bald
middle-eastern weird teeth it's like the
[ __ ] veneers that was like like they
call it the toilet bowl teeth when it's
white it's really I don't know cuz there
are bad veneers like a bunch of cheap
lazy line up yeah what happened to this
dude you got desperate for content you
know you know what's crazy were you guys
here what so when like [ __ ] was first
making the move to LA his manager
brought him down to our office to just
like meet other people so they met with
Tim they probably met with David I think
they kicked met with us and so he was
like this super shy kid and it was just
like really eager to get into YouTube
this is just literally right after his
Drake parody videos and so when I met
him he was like a really nice kid like
super humble and then I think after he
blew up he just lost his marbles oh he
did Drake Drake parodies first that was
his first things yeah it was funny he
would take clips from the drake songs
and then like he would use those lines
as he's picking up girls or whatever and
then um yeah but they're like lip
syncing but just the lines of the song
yeah okay so what does he do now
and then what got him really big were
the were the social experiments and
stuff like that this isn't the same dude
that went on a plane to pretend that he
was a right
he's close to that but he'll do it oh so
he's one of those shitty pranksters yeah
I know it's just like he you'll pay
actors to be in his pranks okay yeah we
got caught for it
yeah so his pranks used to be real in
the very beginning but I think it was
hard to come up with content so so you
had to hire people why why is his head
like this but its basis in here good
with body shapes right like yeah you're
really good with I'm always really good
[ __ ] on news before yeah yeah that was
like four years ago or something yeah
it's kind of weird just because like
though we met him so early you know I
mean and then you see like maybe not so
much like what he has become as a person
but definitely like he probably has
issues that he's always had yeah I know
being in the spotlight amplified it
brought him out yeah because i you know
self-esteem issues like self-worth
suicidal thoughts all that other [ __ ]
it's there ya know but then when you
have like this this non-human like
social pressure it turns people into it
just amplifies all those issues you know
what I mean and so for somebody who
lives I always say this to like if you
live and die by comments as a creator
you're gonna have a very very odd says
when I was chasing the numbers chasing
the Fame I did some [ __ ] that literally
sold my dignity for views and money
that's YouTube you start putting on an
act you become a slave to the numbers
you start doing [ __ ] that you wouldn't
do in your actual life so he did take
some time away from the YouTube grind
and so recently he announced that he was
gonna be hosting a free concert
last-minute concert on July 15th name
and in in the name of spreading love and
so he apparently planned all this in
seven days five days before the event
like that's when you finally got the
venue which was at the Greek Theatre
here in LA and yeah so apparently the
event was going really well like
security was fine food there was plenty
of food and water on
Tanna Khan because a lot of people were
gonna say is gonna be fuzzy Khan but
apparently there were 1500 people there
that attended every supper yeah there
were like certain performances going on
it was cool the main thing that wasn't
he calling it like the biggest concert
of the century or so he was comparing it
to the next like Coachella like he was
saying like 1500 a little afar fellow
yeah and then soso chuckling there yeah
so then he kept saying that Drake was
gonna show up like he kept promising
fans like hey I met Drake she's gonna be
here he said he was gonna come and so a
lot of people had these expectations
that all these different celebrities
were gonna show up even like Kanye was I
don't know like just a lot of people if
you said Bart was gonna show up I would
I showed up he even invited I meet a man
named drop me yeah yeah so then right
before Drake was about to show up that's
when there was a bomb threat like
someone called a bomb threat and cops
showed up evacuated everyone then he
started jumped he apparently gave the
you to you he apparently gave an uber
driver $50,000 or promised him $50,000
so he can stand on top of his cart and
then have like this whole like yeah
they're talking to all the fans that
were there I think he would have done it
for 500 bucks yeah the [ __ ] $50,000
just stand on your car I'm gonna [ __ ]
guess you could stand on the tip of my
dick for 50,000 but did he give them the
50,000 even at one point even the uber
drivers stood on top of the car with him
too and so I'm going to show you guys
forget the new color
you know dramaalert
King yeah so the dude from drama alert
he was apparently filming a documentary
about this entire event
he told fouseytube that he was gonna
film the event
I mean filmed this documentary and that
fouseytube was like super excited he was
happy for it but then there's like so
many details that there's so much that
happened in this entire thing that
there's no way I can cover everything
but let me just show you this quick clip
of fouseytube on top of the Ober
yelling directly at keemstar so here we
go
a pop-top on good question yeah what
happened to his teeth patient brought on
dude here we go cuz I've said I want to
be life and have a face-to-face
conversation what I'm saying is that hey
I'm just telling you as a man at 28
years old what I feel you ain't you want
to commit suicide last year I wanted to
kill myself because the altercation gave
me I'd be watched videos went viral
after the addiction giving me now of you
saying OC is the biggest piece of [ __ ]
egotistical [ __ ] on this earth I have
bipolar depression that what you put
into my head make me want to tell by now
oh I think he was coming back like
you're just promoting your new song
oh yeah so they're like you know what so
hilarious I love you know why I mean for
me I I feel bad because you got to
realize like for someone I like
observing things if you guys haven't
noticed like I like observing things a
lot did you see this go down no I just I
would just watch in that clip
listen to what people say [ __ ] keemstar
it's all about love yeah hilarious by
himself contradicting yes so people are
so weird
I can't wrap my head around it like I
just don't get it you know what I mean
so like him as a person he he knows he's
bipolar you know what I mean if he says
he's bipolar and he's like brave enough
to say it out there and they're like
he's clinically bipolar then he has like
a mental issue he's actually off his
meds too apparently that's according to
him yeah which I don't even know what's
true it's yeah it's so crazy because
like it's so we've known them we've met
him you know like I've hung out with
them he used to train at our gym and all
that and then like I know one side of
them it's possible that he's bipolar and
all that but then there's like this
other side where like if you are bipolar
and being on social media is like one of
the most difficult and mentally
challenging things you can do you should
probably do yourself a favor if you
truly have a mental health issue that's
almost like saying like I have low blood
cell count or whatever and then I'm
gonna be a marathon runner like you just
don't do that you can go work in a
cubicle somewhere and it also kind of
sucks that if you do have it now you're
blaming someone else for it like yours
like bipolar and being depressed and
being suicidal
it's a cumulation of a bunch of factors
and he's putting all of that on one
channel of that one channel one that one
guy giving him suicidal thoughts when he
himself has his own thoughts too and I
don't think that's right because then
now there's all these other people that
are like yeah if Lucy ever dies it's
your fault and it's like yeah it's
things aren't ever like just black and
white like that what was the drama
between him and keemstar that would
viral well team you know team's always
doing some kind of video and exposing or
you know
t-time whatever right but then I think
the extent to which he does it and
executes his content it's very toxic and
mean so I think that's basically what
Lucy was saying in that video is kind of
like the extent to which you know
keemstar was talking about him whether
it's true or not or whatever or if it's
just reporting the how mean it was
really pushed him to the edge but then
at the same time too like he signed up
to be a social media star like fousey
signed up for this [ __ ] you're gonna be
your people are gonna criticize you
people are gonna be hateful toward you
people are gonna talk [ __ ] toward you
especially if you got caught doing fake
content it's the thing that you put out
with using yeah you know you put out
there yeah you like admitted to doing it
doing apologize right like faking his
pranks or whatever but yeah but you're
you're you're gonna be up for criticism
like that so it just goes full circle
you can't really pick and choose what
you want people to say about you but
also there's just this other side of
YouTube where a lot of drama is
exaggerated and orchestrated in order to
get more views in order because that's
the side of [ __ ] that I don't like and
it all started happening when all the
new Viner started coming into YouTube
before that we were all just creating
content and it was it was just fun [ __ ]
but I hate covering this kind of stuff
on JK news because I don't like I don't
like beating this [ __ ] fire you know
it makes it people get all [ __ ] toxic
and then it feeds that [ __ ] viewcount
but you know this reason this you know
what else happened is booth what's his
name
Shane Dawson he was recently on the that
that Adams podcast it was a for our
interview with keemstar Shane Dawson
Yousef and all those guys weren't
supposed to be scheduled on but then Sam
pepper came in and he was confronting
fousey and then I guess team and who's
the other guy I forgot yeah yeah but
they all came in to confront fouseytube
and in so it was like a three four hour
of whatever was going on I don't know
how honest it was I don't know how
reaiiy it's just now there's just so
much to that Q is like profiting off of
and even use of himself said it too is
like you're profiting off of whatever
I'm sending out there cuz he's the one
doing this documentary it's a three-part
documentary on this whole thing and so a
lot of his fans are saying like how are
you gonna be profiting off of that when
he was the one that is trying to spread
love and positivity because the name of
his event was hate dies love arrives and
so but then teams team was also pointing
out the fact that all of a sudden
Yussef have this diss track on rice gum
but then use of a saying it's not a diss
track you gotta listen deep into the
lyrics and then it's just like it's so
much you know what I like though is ksi
and Logan Paul are gonna be boxing so
all of this drama if it's gonna lead up
to boxing oh yeah hope it's setting up
for that I agree I like that I really do
[ __ ] hate how YouTube is right now me
too storytelling [ __ ] I've seen some
[ __ ] like like for instance they go
order coffee and they accidentally put
too much sugar and the top of the video
is they tried to poison me like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you [ __ ] people
dude I hate this [ __ ] man like you know
if you think about it like this usually
like how things work with - the internet
it's like there's a village of people
right the intelligent people the smart
people on the run that runs a village if
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] is that we call
the village idiot you shut the [ __ ] up
and you wait for the smart people to
talk and that's how these things
function and it works really well now we
just have a bunch of idiots that bunched
together and and now we're feeding on
feeding these idiots and I'm saying like
not I'm saying like the youth is done
but when we were young - we made a lot
of dumb choices but we had barriers that
kind of helped us guide us a little
better but now because like feeding
these like stupid inhibitions is
profitable that's what's happening so
you see like these things like there's
phrases that people say that you don't
really believe for example this right
here it's all about love and positivity
however you speak it but you don't act
it yeah they keep feeding that [ __ ] you
know I mean I love if you don't let me
[ __ ] you that's the exact
that's like a like when when people are
like hey that's what is it better be
calm be a t-shirt yeah that's crazy
it's like insane because their fanbase
is so [ __ ] young and stupid intense
it's like they don't see it they don't
see it like just because you have a
positive hashtag does it make you a
better person I mean just that just the
whole thing that happened right the fact
that he's calling him out in front of
his fans like here Dinu Hugh yeah like
his game all right that are gonna attack
him and then to attack them like that
like if it really hurt you I'm not
saying it didn't hurt I'm gonna like if
it really hurt you you just have that
conversation in a room with just you two
and you hash it out on top of a [ __ ]
car with a crop top it's almost like he
wants to know like yo everybody here
comment right now comment right now on
this conversation it's like he's is a
walking literal at YouTube layout
walking around yeah like he could just
let's let's be humans about it you and
me go in a room and talk like how did I
[ __ ] you over how did you [ __ ] squash
him that's being a man because he's like
I told him when I see him face to face
over now this conversation it's like but
your honor with a sea of people leave
your fans yeah yeah he also said to he's
like this is the first time we're
meeting face to face and kings like we
met at my office yeah when you sign the
documents that I can shoot this
documentary on you he was brave enough
to do this just because he had a sea of
supporters it's a culture of criticism
dude like everybody wants to critique
somebody yeah I mean it you want to feel
superior because you could criticize
with somebody else else does yeah
without having your background you know
and it's so weird so for example there's
a comment yesterday and I cracked up
right she goes your videos not funny and
I kind of wrote back and I was like okay
well you should take criticism from what
people say from your art I was like but
who are you
yeah cool who are you in order for you
to critique somebody else's work you
need to have a body of work that
represents what I'm doing yeah if you
could do it better you let me know
however I'm funny you know and that's
why I like sometimes like it's just like
it's hard it's an uphill battle for like
adults now because now like people who
are sensible are trying to speak this
[ __ ] into but now they think that
they're the sensible people and they're
trying to talk to you
yeah that's wild right it's wild it's
all love [ __ ] you David yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] baby it's all about positivity
[ __ ] [ __ ] of you dumb [ __ ] I was
like that's like without me [ __ ] you
like me before fighting racism but then
they end up being racist like the like
shut up don't be racist you cracker
[Music]